vous dites que vous êtes une enfant
précoce vous dormi en classe y paraît en
fait au début on est au début j'étais
une enfant précoce et donc je m'ennuyais
en classe ça c'était trop facile pour
vous en fait les enfants précoces il
faut savoir que en fait il faut les il
faut les nourrir oui si on les nourrit
pas en fait il s'étiole donc ouais
j'avais j'avais j'avais des cantons
s'est aperçu que j'étais précoce on m'a
fait sauter une classe vous avez eu
votre bac après ça après ça c'est ça
s'est super bien passé formé
mémé cesser les troubles de
l'apprentissage de l'enfant c'est des
sujets très importants à l'école il faut
repérer il ya ceux qui ont qui sont
hyperactifs et ceux qui ont des troubles
dys et il ya les enfants précoces et il
faut les repérer très jeune le bac s
c'est pour ça que je veut réformer la
médecine scolaire d'ailleurs parce que
aujourd'hui il ya des choses à faire on
en reparlera vous parlera de tout ça
vous parlerai de votre programme c'est
vrai que paca saison s'est formé à 16
ans j'étais en cm2
j'ai pas toujours été bons élèves voient
dans la série - en cm2 ont prôné pour le
prof déjà à 20 environ là c'est plus
compliqué vous êtes victime d'une
agression sexuelle ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter ce qui s'est passé valait
alors j'avais j'avais 22 ans
et en fait c'est quelque chose dont j'ai
mis du temps à parler parce qu'en fait
je pense qu'il ya une espèce de 2,2 de
stress post traumatique qu'on dit
maintenant par excès moi la mode est en
fait ce qui fait qu'on n'en parle pas
donc un jour un jour en fait cet
agression c était quoi pour moi ça a été
la fin de l'insouciance
j'étais insouciant tu vois là j'avais 22
ans je portais du courte je me méfie de
personnes j'avais confiance voilà et un
jour
j'allais voir un copain et j'étais je
rentrais dans un immeuble et j'ai ouvert
la porte avec le code à un type qui
était derrière moi on est entrés
ensemble dans l'île dans l'immeuble et
c'était un immeuble qui avait pas
l'ascenseur donc j'ai commencé à monter
dans l'escalier et il m'a sauté dessus
dans l'escalier et j'ai hurlé et
football bol comme j'allais voir un ami
l'ami m'attendais c'était un vieil
immeuble et on entendait tout dans
l'immeuble il m'a entendu en l'air et il
a ouvert la porte et il s'est précipité
et le type a détalé ici en fille mais
donc il s'est rien passé ça rien de
dramatique rhin terrible simplement
simplement le choc de me dire ben voilà
en fait l'autre en face de moi ça peut
être un agresseur ça peut être un mec
qui qui qui qui veut me violer quoi vous
saurez but quand vous en reparler
oui parce que c'est parce que j'en ai
jamais parlé à la télé comme ça vraiment
j'en ai parlé un peu vaguement mais mais
mais voila voila mais mais parce que je
sais que beaucoup de femmes beaucoup de
filles ont vécu sa vie ça que beaucoup
comme moi n'ont pas osé en parler parce
que moi j'ai pas osé porter plainte et
ce dont je me veux m'en veux maintenant
c'était c'était il ya longtemps c'était
il ya trente ans mais je m'en veux
maintenant parce que je me dis peut-être
que le type il a recommencé mais à
l'époque j'ai voulu j'ai fait le black
out j'ai voulu tourner la page de sa gg
plus voulu en parler il s'était rien
passé j'ai voulu tourner après et je
pense qu'il ya plein de femmes de faire
d'avis comme ça c'est ça et donc quand
je suis devenue présidente de région
il se trouve que j'ai l'âge et
responsabilités du métro mais dans le
métro il ya plein de l'agression et donc
je me suis dit il faut que je fasse des
campagnes pour dire au témoin ou victime
porté plainte voilà briser l'omerta
n'ayez pas peur parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle est dans un commissariat pour
raconter ça il m'aurait dit quoi
deviennent jupe courte où il y avait
ouvert la porte
pourquoi voulez-vous ouvert la porte
allez moi j'avais peur de façon dont
j'allais être aussi aussi dans le
commissariat si on allait me prendre au
sérieux c'est un très joli nom mais dans
les commissariats vous n'y prenez
vraiment au sérieux c'est ce genre
d'agression maintenant oui maintenant
oui avant il y avait un hashtag qui
s'appelait double peine pour les femmes
victimes de violences mais aujourd'hui
vraiment les choses ont changé - moi
j'ai fait faire un audit de tous les
commissariats qui a été demandé par la
préfecture de police j'ai une
association qui travaille pour la région
ile de france et on l'a fait pour la
région et il faut le faire dans tous les
commissariats de france
aujourd'hui il faut que ces femmes
soient reçus et moi je demande dans mon
programme qui est une juridiction
spécialisée c'est à dire des juges
spécialisés pour les violences faites
aux femmes et que dans les 72 heures on
puisse prendre des mesures parce que
aujourd'hui malheureusement il ya encore
beaucoup trop de violences faites aux
femmes alors vous êtes entré à l'ina
vous terminerez deuxième de votre
troupeau
c'est un parcours parfait vous apprenez
des japonais vous partez vendre des
spiritueux des caméscopes et des
liqueurs à tokyo c'est fou ça
alors ouais en fait je suis parti
apprendre le japonais est pour pour
payer mon voyage j'ai envoyé des lettres
à plein d'entreprises en leur disant
écoutez je pars au japon pour suivre des
cours de japonais en fait j'ai aimé un
peu l'aventuré j'avais a fait du russe
je mets ça vous vous êtes vous avez déjà
donné j'avais envie de j'avais j'avais
envie de voyager envie de découvrir le
monde mais il fallait aussi financé et
donc c'est moi tes chandon là les
champagnes lorsque devoir citer d'autres
champagne par le champomy
une grande marque de champagne mais une
grande marque de champagne qui m'a
répondu alors je suis allé chez eux à
epernay il voulait vous vendre un
mélange de cognac et champagne au jeune
japonaise parce qu'elle aime le
champagne mais elle est mêlée cocktail
sucré donc ça sert à peine la petite
clique heures je vous rassure à la fin
de mon étude de marché puisque j'en ai
fait boire à des japonaises pendant deux
mois et demi
à la fin de l utile de marché j'ai
conclu qu'il n'y avait pas de marché
pour la petit clic heures c'était trop
sucrés et ça marchait pas elle boit
vraiment bien glacées et c'était pas
terrible on souligna que champagne je
retiens aussi c'est que vous par les
japonais est-ce que japonais je serai la
prochaine présidente de la république
française alors je vais vous dire je les
a pris oui mais aujourd'hui je ne parle
plus du tout alors je peux simplement
faire quelque chose qui est qui qui
impressionne toujours les japonais sait
que je peux lire du japonais si on fait
un discours non et l'autre et j'ai fait
un discours comme ça à l'université de
tokyo quand j'étais ministre et tous les
japonais ont cru que je parlais japonais
de glisse sont tous très sereins non je
ne le parle plus et d'ailleurs j'ai même
vous faire une confidence
mon fils qui est aujourd'hui est un
lecteur fans de mangas le clément
baptiste
clément d'accord c'est un fan absolu de
manga aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que
temps en temps ils parlent mieux avec
moi il apprend les expressions japonaise
avec les mangas donc il me mit il me met
des gommes entzheim et des ira chasser
toutes les cinq minutes mais donc lui
lui il commence à bien un petit quelque
chose ce qu'était vous avez vous avez
trois enfants valérie baptiste clément
et emilie est-ce que c'est compliqué de
gérer une campagne présidentielle et de
gérer sa vie de famille parce que c'est
vrai que c'est très très prononcé alors
je dois avouer que le fait que le niçois
vide mais c'est à dire que les trois
soient parties cette année de la maison
ca y est c'est fini
c'est vraiment important parce que ça me
permet de me donner vraiment à 120 %
dans la campagne parce que j'aurai
aujourd'hui encore des enfants petit moi
je ne sais pas comment comment marion
maréchal fait mais c'est c'est à dire la
vie politique c'est dur quand on a des
enfants petit parce que il faut vraiment
tout concilier moi je me suis inventé à
certains moments des rendez vous
extrêmement important avec des gens
extrêmement important parce qu'en fait
il fallait que je me dépêche de courir à
la librairie acheter des stylos feutres
pour ma fille qui avait malheureusement
oublié ses stylos feutres et il fallait
que à un moment donné j'avais les
chercher donc voilà
vraiment faire de la politique pour une
femme c'est encore plus dur alors je
sais que maintenant il ya des nouveaux
pères qui font ça très bien et qui
assume le partage des tâches j'ai
d'ailleurs vu que dans certains
programmes même nos hommes politiques
parlent d'égalité salariale et d'égalité
moi j'ai le partage des tâches ça a été
dans l'adn de mon couple pendant 28 ans
alors si vous êtes élu président de la
république je n'ai parlé que marine le
pen nationale elle me dit moi je n'aurai
pas de premier homme vous vous en avez
un est-ce qu'il va arrêter de travailler
ou bien est-ce qui va continuer ses
activités c'est une question qui est
très importante ah oui parce qu'en fait
mon mari
il est il est
et cadres dirigeants dans une dans une
grande entreprise internationale est en
fait c'est pas compatible avec le fait
d'être premier et tout d'une président
de la république parce que aujourd'hui
quand on est dans le secteur privé on
peut pas avoir sa femme qui est
président la république donc ça veut
dire qu'on avait déjà parlé tous les
deux bien sûr on en a parlé ensemble et
il est prêt il est prêt à y renoncer par
amour pour moi
[Applaudissements]